let me ask you about Alex Epstein
so he wrote I'm not sure if you're
familiar who he is but he wrote a couple
of books it's just interesting to ask a
question about fossil fuels because
we're talking about reality and he's
somebody that doesn't just talk about
the reality of fossil fuels but he wrote
a book uh moral case for fossil fuels
and uh fossil future where he makes the
case
that as his subtitle says Global human
flourishing requires oil coal and
natural gas or more oil coal and natural
gas not less
uh what do you think about the argument
he makes so he he pushes we've had this
kind of speaking of the center of this
balanced discussion of the reality of
fossil fuels but also investing a lot
into renewable energy and that having
the one dollar to eleven dollar return
so he says like
I'm not sure exactly how to frame it but
like investing and maintaining
investment to fossil fuels also has a
positive return because of how efficient
the energy is I've read the first book
yeah I haven't read I've got just a
second one I've been planning to have
them on my webcast my tiny webcast
sustain what everything I do is sustain
what because it's like don't talk to me
about sustainability sustain what for
whom how then we're talking you know
um interrogatory approach to things so
um
I think the valuable part of what he has
done is to remind people
particularly in the west or north or
whatever the developed world that
everything we take for granted
low fertilizer from low fertilizer
prices to air conditioning to everything
else exists because we had this bounty
that we dug out of the ground or pumped
out of the ground
it's a boon it's been an amazing Boon to
society period so start there which
means going forward what we're talking
about is a substitution
or
having your fossil fuel isn't eating it
too meaning getting rid of the carbon
dioxide if you focus on the carbon
dioxide
which is the thing warming the planet
not the burning of the fuels
then that's another way forward that
could sustain fossil fuels as far as I
can tell from at least the first book he
makes the moral case the fossil fuels
are essentially a good
overall
um I don't think he adequately accounts
for the need
to stop global warming you know I think
that we have to slow slowing global
warming is a fundamental need in this
coming in this Century we're in
and that's just not factored into his
math well I think that's where and I've
had a few sort of offline conversations
with them and I think he he said because
I mentioned I'm talking to the two you
said that he that's probably why he
disagrees about sort of the the level of
threat that
um global warming causes well Steve
coonan is another one uh he he's a
brilliant guy he lived right close to me
in Hudson Valley he was in the Obama
Administration energy Department it's
k-o-o-n-i-n he wrote a bestseller that
came out recently on
skepticism about climate
um and um
other there are other smart people who
somehow feel we can literally adapt our
way forward without any constraint on
the gases changing the climate and I you
know
I've spent a lot of time on this I think
I'm a pretty level-headed reporter when
it comes to this issue and I think
having some sense that
we can adapt our way into the world
we're building through Relentless
climate change with no new normal
remember
more gas accumulating in the air every
year
these are not static moments
that that's a good thing to do is
doesn't strike me as
um
smart I'd probably say that I I think
it's more sort of a at least the thing
that I take away from Alex is um is the
fact as as you point out that we need to
recognize that fossil fuels is basically
the backbone of our society today we get
80 of our energy from fossil fuels to
still as we did 50 years yeah four years
ago yeah yeah and and people have no
sense of this right so they have the
idea because you see so many wind
turbines and solar panels and
everybody's talking about that this is
huge big things but the reality is
remember only about a fifth of all
energy uses electricity the rest is you
know in processes and heating industrial
processes and so on so uh actually you
know solar and wind right now produces
one percent from of energy from wind and
0.8 percent from solar this is not a
huge thing it's a fairly tiny bit and
growing explosively yes it's absolutely
gross but actually it's growing slower
than what nuclear it was growing in the
70s and 80s which I thought was a fun
Point not by a little amount by like two
or three times so so we're we're still
talking about you know something which
is you know somewhat Boutique at least
and and when you then look out into the
future and and I think this is the
interesting part of it when you look out
into the future if you look at the Biden
administration's own estimate of what
will happen by 2050.
we will be at you know if all countries
do all the stuff that they promised and
everything we will be at 70 percent
fossil fuels by 2015. globally this this
is just yes it's a it's a better world I
I think it's good that we're now down to
70 instead of of 80. but it is still a
world that's fundamentally dependent on
fossil fuels for almost everything that
we really like about the world and
forgetting that and I think we are doing
that in the sense as you also mentioned
that people say no fossil fuels and you
know we're in all development
organizations we're now telling the poor
countries you can't get any funding for
anything that has to do with fossil
fuels we have literally reduced our our
uh investment in uh in oil and gas by
more than half since 2014 and much of
this is because of climate concerns this
has real world consequences this is why
an Enterprises have gone up it's not the
only reason covet also certainly the war
in Ukraine but this is an underlying
systemic reason why fossil fuel costs
will go up dramatically now a lot of
greens will sort of tend to say well
that's great because you know we want
fossil fuels to be expensive we want
people to be forced over to Renewables
but that's very easy to say if you're
rich you know it's the kind of thing
that New Yorkers will say you know when
when you go to Rich well-meaning uh
Green New Yorkers and say Yes gasoline
should cost twenty dollars a gallon well
you don't have a car just right at the
Metro it's very easy for you to say that
but lots of people both in the rich
world but you know in in poor parts of
the US but all around the world their
lives have basically dependent on fossil
fuels and so the idea that we're going
to get people off by making it so
expensive that it becomes impossible for
them to live good lives is almost
morally reprehensible and I think Alex
has the right point there we need to get
people to realize we're not going to get
off fossil fuels anytime soon so we need
reasonably affordable fossil fuels for
most of the world and that's of course
course why we need to focus so much more
on the Innovation so that we can get to
the point where we no longer need fossil
fuels as soon as possible but to say to
everyone look we're going to make fossil
fuels expensive way before we have the
solution is just terrible and the rich
the so much is on the rich countries of
the world
um
I did a conversation recently with
Johann rockstrom who's a famed
sustainability scientist in Stockholm
actually Potsdam now um right and he's
come up with the idea of planetary
boundaries you know there's lots of
things he has said that I as a
journalist I'm still looking into about
that planetary boundaries yeah that
there are limits to what Earth can
absorb and human be our use of water
phosphorus or carbon dioxide loading in
the atmosphere there are these tipping
there are these boundaries if we cross
them we're in a Hot Zone a danger zone
right he's an interesting thinker but on
this point last year at the Glasgow
climate talks he gave a very important
talk about
the equity thing here that you
he basically laid out a landscape
saying the rich nations of the world
need to greatly ramp up their reduction
of emissions or what they're going to
pay for countries to do to allow poor
countries
some of which have fossil resources like
in Africa
to have the carbon space to to own
whatever space or time is left to be
able to develop their their
fossil fuels
as a fundamental right because also they
are starting from this little Baseline
gagana hasn't contributed squat to the
global warming problem in terms of
emissions Ghana has natural gas and
right now this month the environmental
groups are
outside the world bank today actually
tonight
saying this was on their list of dirty
projects World Bank should stop
financing Ghana's right to get gas out
of the ground to develop its economy get
its people less poor make them more
productive Innovative parts of humanity
it's to me that's really reprehensible
one of the other projects on their list
as the World Bank kind of gotcha like
how dare they give money
it was for a new for a fertilizer
Factory in Bangladesh that is designed
to get three times as much fertilizer
from the same amount of natural gas as
the old plants that are not dormant
that's this is in a time when we're
facing High Energy prices high gas
prices high high food prices when food
insecurity is spreading rapidly when a
country like Bangladesh has millions of
rice farmers who need
urea
tablets to put in their rice fields and
to say that shouldn't that that how dare
they finance that because there's a
fossil fuel involved is immoral so so
yes on that point from Alex